hi again so cheer chap too
the
the believing in god believing in
o scentsy believing in your grandparents
or whoever you want to believe in has
passed away
i would
i don't know what the general consensus
is whether people
out there
think that
they want would like to think there's
life after death but
there isn't
and nobody can prove it anyhow
i'm one of these people that you know if
i say to you
this is a pink piece of paper with a
white dot
already your brain will be thinking why
did he say pink when it's white
so it makes you question it makes you
start to think
if i say to you
okay this
piece of white paper with a black dye in
it
of course it it'll go in
but it's really
just
not absorbed
in the same way your brain's not
starting to think why did he say
why do you sound like this over the
black spot
so i'm just trying to get you thinking
in the the way that
i'm going to go about
this conversation
perhaps if you're brought up like me in
a religious environment you're taught
that we all have a guardian angel
well let's uh dilute that down a little
bit and say when you get a bit older you
don't start thinking there's angels
next to you
but
perhaps i
do have a guide perhaps if there is an
after
life
really if you know
if something leaves our
physical body that's inside us
i can't see it i can't feel it
but they call it inca in catholicism
they call it a soul
perhaps
my soul leaves my body
so
if
there's uh some kind of or say spiritual
belief that
inside us
we do have something that
cannot be seen by us
but we'd like to believe in it
it can be classed as a summer
now
does our soul is it a sort of spiritual
form
of us
is it a 3d
hologram
or what is it
that when we die
it leaves our physical frame
the frame you know that has a finger
that can push the nuclear button
push a click on a camera turn a light
switch on
pick up a gun
kill somebody
rock a baby giving it love
these are physical things that we can do
with this physical body that we've got
but what does this spirit do inside us
why would you talk to your spirit if
it's inside you
because why would you say oh dear why
why always me why does it always have to
happen to me
why can't i have a break for a change
right you know you might be asking these
questions
but you might be throwing them out there
the same as i threw this white piece of
paper the black dot
if i
throw out the
pink piece of paper with a black dot
then you start to think and you think
okay well
if i'm going to be talking to myself
because that's what it ends up being
why me
why do i always get the bad luck
no i'm never lucky no point in me buying
a lottery ticket
and yet you buy one
i've never been lucky never won anything
in my life
and yet you'll enter competitions
so there's still some glimmer of hope in
there isn't that
so let's take that glimmer of hope and
put it into
perhaps there's life after death
i ask a question
but i'm not listening to the answer well
the answer is inside me isn't it if my
spirit's in there if there's a hologram
or 3d
copy carbon copy of tony sergeant inside
me already
and what's the point in asking that for
answers
because i might be
listening listening
no i can't i can't get anything
anyhow
just to jump to us
around a little as i wish to do in this
chit chat session
i was asked by a friend to go and stay
with them for a weekend
he's nike doger met a new lady in his
life
they invited me and jane to go and stay
with them for the weekend i'm not really
a sociable animal but after
i don't know 30 40 years of
having the person as a student
they stopped being a student and end up
being a good friend
oh
i didn't realize that you liked
gardening when we arrived there you
asked first of all ah who does the
gardening
and this is me being judgmental that i
try not to be but
obviously that's part of the human trait
uh who does a guarding but
like the white piece of paper
or pink
i expected it
to be
said
oh
it's my partner she does it
so i'd already thought they said
so why you bother to ask the question
why don't just go straight to her and
say you keep your garden really nice
it's the same thing as when you say
somebody oh how are you i'll find thanks
and yeah they might be terrible but they
don't want to tell you the truth because
they know that you're not really
interested
and if you start telling them you're
true aches pains and problems
they might be like the baby rocking they
might be actually
sympathetic
caring and
truly concerned
but the majority of people won't be and
they would like to just get on with
their busy life
and what's happening to them rather than
listening to you about your
problems
sorry if i'm sounding a little negative
there
so i asked the question
and it came back that he was the
gardener
he loved gardening
he said didn't you know that and i go
well why would i only know you're in the
role of
aikido i teach you like you know you
come here you drive 120 miles one way
you drive under him i was back just an
hour and a half's lesson
to me you're very dedicated student
but i didn't know he was a king gardener
i mean
ken's not the word he's a looks like a
fanatical garden precision detail
what he grows
he did go on to say how it was joined
and now they both enjoy the garden
so then there's harmony there isn't that
both parties who are enjoying their
garden
so we don't always know about the things
that each other's other
does and why would we i'm talking to you
you might be interested in
many things but you might be just coming
to my particular site
for
a specific items
let's say i i grow roses
and i like a special red climbing rose
you would come to me
to get knowledge about that
and yet like you i do so many other
things in with my life
that
people don't know about you won't know
about
perhaps you do some of you do
who have known me long enough they know
i'm a bit wacky a bit off the wall yet
you stick by me
so
one of my passions is
i didn't know whether i wanted to
believe in
having a
a guide you know always by my side
this you know who is this guy i want to
know more
no i don't really want to know more
because
i haven't really found any help from
them
then i thought well
perhaps you're not
you're telling you're saying why me why
do i have so much bad luck but you're
never actually listening to the answers
so when i went on this uh
retreat once
i've been a few times i went on this
retreat one
where they teach psychics
so
you've got aikido you've got tai chi
yoga meditation
i do healing work as well
i love gardening
i used to keep a special breed of
rabbits i used to keep tropical birds
i then
also kept
budgie regards
i could go on telling you about all the
things that you may not know about me
the same as i don't know things about
you
so i go on this uh psychic seminar
and
i may have told
talked about this before
and this gentleman goes into trance and
he starts drawing
and he says he's been led by
somebody that i knew
and he dropped this picture i'll show
you now
and he said
this is your spirit guide sorry about
that the shininess i'll turn it a bit so
you can see
if i divided it you would see that
there's two faces going straight down
through the nose section
there's actually a caucasian
and the other half is a of an indian
so how i've ended up with um
one spirit guide
but who's had two lives i've no idea i'm
still searching that one out
anyhow he gave me this picture and i've
had that done
and a frame of another one
so
i decided that um
i was quite dumbfounded by and i thought
is it real i mean you know somebody's
just drawn this
and i was in a very confused state but
also a very happy state because i
thought oh at last
i've actually got i do have a guide i
actually have somebody i can talk to
i've actually got friends
yes i've got a friend in my partner
jane i've got
my children
i've got lots of friends
but i don't know this was different it
had a different feel to it
so i lay in bed that night
in this center
and it has quite heavy
duvet and it had some what it considers
old-fashioned blankets
so there was not a light covering on me
but as i lay there
it felt as if
i was becoming
the sausage
in a warm
hot sausage roll that just been freshly
made
i don't really know how to explain it
but i was
not smothered
but i was contained
and within that containment i lay in the
middle
but the contained feeling around me was
of warmth and love as i'd never in my
human life experienced before
i didn't share this information with
anybody for
years
because i didn't really know how to
explain it
but the love is something not this world
or
i have not yet experienced it
at that at this point in time
and this
evening
i did experience it
and i knew then and i don't know why i
knew but i knew then
that
i'd made
or i should say my guide this the
picture of this person in the spirit
world
was showing me that the connection was
there
and made
i was also told telepathically or
however i received it
that i wouldn't feel it again in my
lifetime
because it took such a
large amount of energy
to perform this
or say caressing
of joining us together and me
certain knowing with certainty
that that wasn't me doing this
but it was a connection being made
proving to me that
there is life after death
and there was some
thing
energy
spirit soul there was something
that was there and was there for me for
the rest of my life
all i've got to do
is realize that it was there to help me
and help me in thought
because
like me when i pass
my hologram
my spirit or whatever
will no longer be able to push a button
hold a baby
but the hologram will be able to show to
somebody on the living plane
if they have this insight
that there is something there of the
person who was
while on the earth plane what form of
body they they had and what they looked
like
i hope you found this interesting
i thought i was only going to make two
chit chat films
but i'll have a small pause and i'll
then carry on
i hope you're finding it interesting or
perhaps i will see everybody leaving my
patreon and my youtube channel thinking
i don't want to follow that nutter any
longer
it's your choice
but
i hope that
i've made you think about the pink piece
of paper with the white dot on it
thank you